In this lesson, we define
the dual of a linear program and
showed how this dual program
can be seen as the problem
of making a certain kind of bound on
the primal program as tight as possible.
Then we saw how maximum flow and
maximum bipartite matching can be
expressed as linear programs, and
how the minimum ST cut and
vertex cover problems were their duals.
If this idea of duality appeals to you,
I suggest looking at the primal dual
algorithm for solving the near programs.
Although this is not
a practical strategy for
solving general linear programs,
it has served as the inspiration for
many algorithms for
specific types of problems.
In fact, the Ford-Fulkerson
algorithm which we studied and
the famous Hungarian algorithm for
finding minimum cost matchings,
can be seen as primal dual algorithms.
Those are good places to start.
More broadly, the type of duality that
we've studied has profound implications
for game theory, convex geometry,
and convex optimization.
Keep this lesson in mind when
you encounter those topics.